conseils beauté aux abois oui malaisie
un conseil beauté à donner oui alors
très bien mais bon
alors aujourd'hui il ya un petit détail
spéciaux les remarques et je ne sais pas
à faire chez vous j'ai mis un peu de
vert et ça donne un regard un peu plus
mais ça c'est pas vous faut la voir chez
vous passez pas obligatoire
non j'ai un conseil ça c'est vrai une
fois par semaine si vous pouvez un petit
peeling chimique c'est rien du tout un
public suivi sa souris naines non
absolument non alors là c'est parce que
c'est le nom commun le gommage saabine
un peu la pousse à se frottent alors que
peeling chimique c'est une petite crème
que vous achetez vous passer comme ça
vous dit c'est juste cinq minutes ce
sont des acides de fruits qui viennent
manger des petites particules
je vous promets que derrière vous avez
une peau magnifique être que sur le
village il faut pas au malheur partout
banon annonce au village que son visa
non mais c'est vrai je pourrais faire
des tutos peut-être mais non je pourrais
faire mais ça c'est vraiment un truc à
faire une fois par semaine y en a des
pas très cher bien sûr que la lettre est
cherché la prairie dior tout ça mais
vous pouvez commencer dans avec vos
moyens
un pas très cher il merci pas très bons
conseils beauté
[Applaudissements]